(sad music)
(breaking glass)
- Hey, how is everything going in here?
- Yeah, you know,
just getting some last-minute things done
before we take her.
I'm gonna take her to all
of her favorite places
and then I'm gonna spread her ashes.
- And I'm here to celebrate her life
by fulfilling her last dying wish of
finishing this bar cart
and watching her favorite
show, The Husband Did It.
- Yes, okay, that is lovely.
She was so lucky to have
two great granddaughters
like you.
- [Brunette Woman] No, no, no.
- We were the lucky ones.
(crying)
- Oh my God.
I was her granddaughter,
she was my nanna
- Our grandma.
- She was my nanna.
- She was our nanna.
- We are not related.
It was...
- She actually loved me.
- She's my nanna by blood.
- She told me that before she passed.
- [Brunette Woman] She did not say that.
- Why are you yelling at me.
- Oh my God.
- I'm hurting too.
- [Brunette Woman] All right!
(dubstep music)
All right, you know what?
I'm gonna get going
cause there's not a lot
of time before sundown.
I want you to take my phone.
I want it to be just me and nanna today.
So.
- Okay.
- Also, thank you for helping.
- Wait!
Here.
Shots for nanna.
- Oh.
- To our nanna.
- To my nanna
- Our nanna.
- Kelsey.
- To my nanna, for the love of God.
- Our...
- My nanna.
- Our nanna.
- Okay.
(spits loudly)
- Jesus!
- Why was it a solid?
- How long have these been sitting here?
- I could feel my breath through my nose.
(dubstep music)
Okay, gran, are you ready
to have the best day ever?
Besides, you know, the
fact that you're dead.
(dramatic music)
- [TV] The thing I never told you,
it was me the whole time.
- (laughs) It's not the brother.
The husband did it!
God, I like it every time. (laughs)
(phone vibrates)
Hello.
- Hey, hey! Ms. Peterman!
- No, this is her best
friend, but we're basically...
You know, yes, this is her.
Who's this?
- This is Paul from Live to
Die Another Day Mortuary.
Uh, how are you doing?
- (burps) We're just
hanging in there, Paul.
You know how it is, just hangin in there.
- That's good.
Real quick, there has been a little bit
of a mix-up with the urns this morning.
- What!
- Yeah, it seems there was,
what we call here, a switcher-whoops.
We kind of gave you the wrong urn.
(laughs nervously)
- So, you didn't give us nanna?
- Yes.
- Yes you did, or yes you didn't?
- Didn't.
- Didn't?
- Yes.
- You didn't give us nanna?
- We didn't not switcher-whoops,
to put it plainly.
- Just say that slower down for me.
- We didn't give you the correct urn.
What you have there, is the wrong person.
- Then who do we have?
(mumbles from phone)
Oh
my
God.
Come on.
Pick up, pick up, pick up, pick up.
(phone vibrates)
Fuck!
Okay.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Damn it, I don't know where they are!
Okay, when you're lost, it's
best to stay in one place.
Okay, shit!
This is time-sensitive!
Think, think, think, think, think.
What'd nanna do?
Okay, okay, think, think, think.
(burps loudly)
(phone beeps)
Spread ashes at rooftop. (laughs)
That's lucky.
In 10 minutes!
I gotta get those ashes!
- See ya!
Good luck!
- Thanks!
Fuck I'm drunk.
Should've just walked around.
- She's gonna get there in time.
(rock music)
- All right gram.
It's time.
(rock music)
(brakes squeel)
- What the hell!
I'm eating yogurt!
- My grandma just died!
- Fuck you.
- You wish.
- No I don't.
(drum plays)
(sad music)
- Okay.
(rock music)
(groans)
(sad music)
(tropical music)
- Is there anything else left to do?
You're right, let's just do it.
(jazz music)
- [Girl In Bed] Hey!
- [Kelsey] Hey, Kelsey Guerra.
(sad music)
(tribal music)
(yells)
(sad music)
(tribal music)
Hey!
(glass breaks)
Ow!
- Mm-mm.
- [Kelsey] Wait, Kate, no!
- (screams)
- Oh, fuck!
- What the fuck, Kelsey!
What's wrong with you?
- Oh my God.
Nanna, that's not nanna!
- What are you talking about?
- It's not nanna, they
gave us the wrong urn!
Oh Jesus.
- How do they, how do you
give someone the wrong urn?
What are you...
Who the fuck do I have then if
this isn't nanna?
- Oh my God.
Oh my God, his name was Hanz, right...
If you look under the fucking lid.
- There's a swastika on it!
- He's a...
he's a Nazi.
Yeah.
- Did I just spend a whole beautiful day
with a freaking Nazi?
(upbeat music)
Looks a little bit like
a castle, if you ask me.
What do you think it looks like?
(upbeat music)
(laughs) Grandma!
I have Nazi under my fingernails!
- I have Nazi in my mouth!
(dubstep music)